[Music]
well good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight and of course happy new
year America lasted yet another 12
months as the best country in the world
but it was a turbulent year and 2018
could be even more so so laters tonight
advice on how to thrive over the year
ahead no matter what happens but first
this country's largest state has taken
another dramatic step toward disunion an
open defiance of the federal government
as of yesterday California is now a
sanctuary state it's the nation's first
all police statewide in California are
banned from asking about a suspects
immigration status or cooperating with
federal immigration officials landlords
are banned from reporting the legal
status of their tenants colleges can't
monitor the immigration status of the
kids they enroll these new measures
augment the state's many existing laws
all designed to enable illegal
immigration illegals in California
already are entitled to receive a
driver's license in State College
tuition free healthcare for their
children and more they don't need to
have a job they don't have to know
English doesn't matter even if they have
a history of crime even violent crime in
California illegal aliens are now a
protected class and may be more
significant the state itself is now in
direct opposition to this country's most
basic laws 55 years ago this month
Governor George Wallace took his oath of
office and pledged resistance to federal
authority effectively declaring Alabama
its own country you know the history
well Governor Jerry Brown of California
has done something similar this week
Travis Allen is a Republican in the
California State Assembly and he joins
us tonight mr. Allen thanks come on
thanks so much Tucker so California is
the biggest state but it's still a state
not a country how can it have its own
immigration policy how can it redefine
citizenship when it's not a country
simply put it can't this whole sanctuary
state is entirely illegal and we're
actually welcoming Trump and sessions to
come out to California and take them to
court but how does this end I mean when
when states declare publicly we're not
following the laws of the country we're
making our own laws and there's nothing
you can do about it I mean that sounds
like the beginning of
Schism split a war without a doubt I
mean California truly has become the
center of the quote/unquote resistance
to the President and everything that
seems to make common sense in the United
States so with jerry brown's reached an
action of the sanctuary state
Californians don't even agree with this
but the politicians that are running the
state in sacramento keep in mind the
legislature up until just recently was
two-thirds democrat and all of the
statewide officers are democrat as well
passed this law even though california's
are absolutely against it what's so
striking in the specific case of
california is that the state is
hemorrhaging its middle class they're
moving to neighboring states north and
east in huge numbers and it's been
written about a lot the state doesn't
seem to care and even as this happens
seems to be importing a lot of new much
poor or less educated people what's the
thinking there you know i really don't
know that there is a thinking there you
know a lot of Sacramento and San
Francisco exists really in its own
bubble the numbers came out just
recently two hundred and forty three
thousand Californians have left in just
the last few years taking about eight
billion dollars with them and in their
place of course now we have this
burgeoning illegal population which now
as you mentioned has protected class
status and it gets very bad because you
see this is California taxpayer dollars
being used to shelter criminals who are
committing crimes while they're here and
these aren't these aren't small crimes
we're talking assault on a police
officer domestic battery animal cruelty
possession of concealed weapons
biological agents I mean these are real
crimes and yet Jerry Brown and the
California Democrats want to essentially
ignore federal immigration law and
protect these people at California's
expense and that's just but ignoring
immigration law is not the same as
ignoring other kinds of law because it
gets to the deepest question about any
country which is who's a citizen and
who's not who deserves to be here who
doesn't what our borders and so
California can't that your governor
can't expect this to go ignored you
can't just decide you're not going to
enforce the borders and expect
Washington to do nothing is there a
showdown coming absolutely there is I
mean this is truly it's it's a bluff
and it's up to the president and Jeff
Sessions to step in and call the bluff
of Jerry Brown and all the California
Democrats that are passing these
unconstitutional laws and keep in mind
too you know a lot of people look around
the country say well you know everybody
in California is liberal they're
Democrat and that there could be nothing
further from the truth there's actually
more Republicans here in California than
in any other state and past that forget
about party lines for a moment
seventy-four percent of Californians are
absolutely against sanctuary state
including 65 percent of Latinos well why
wouldn't they be for it I mean people
aren't middle classes in leaving
California because it's thriving the
infrastructure is a mess the schools are
terrible there's more poverty in the
state than any state in the Union I mean
is there a connection do you think
between the state's immigration policies
and the direction of its economy without
a doubt and you mean really you have to
go back a couple of decades the
California Legislature has been
dominated by Democrats by 39 of the last
40 years
yeah the brown family has run California
for 24 of essentially last 50 years so
you need to look no further than than
what has been going on successfully we
had driver's licenses for undocumented
immigrants people who are here illegally
and now this is really just the next
step now it's a sanctuary state all of
these things are unconstitutional but
the California legal system is broken
the California political system is
broken that's why we truly need
Washington to hear this message and come
to California sue California take them
to Supreme Court and let's get the
Constitution in force because there's a
lot of California's here that want to be
protected until we get a new governor in
the state you know I'm running to be the
next governor of California until that
happens we could actually use some help
from the national guys well and it
affects the rest of us too
Assemblyman Allen thank you very much
for joining us without a doubt Chuck
remember what starts here in California
usually spreads to the rest of the
nation so let's put a stop to it like a
virus thanks Kathy rue is the founding
publisher of Catalina magazine and she
joins us tonight Kathy thanks for coming
on so you you can agree or not with the
new policy in California but doesn't it
give you pause that California is BAE
sickly doing what southern states did 50
years ago 60 years ago and saying we're
ignoring federal authority on states
rights grounds we're not going to
acknowledge that your laws valid
liberals used to be against that they're
not anymore it's quite the opposite I
mean they're allowing the federal
government to do what it's supposed to
do the state and local governments are
not supposed to handle immigration and
ask people for their papers so if
anything they're giving the authority
back to the federal government not
taking it into their own hands no
because there are many specific cases
where the state of California as a
matter of policy has refused to hand
over and this law codifies it criminals
to the federal government they were
refusing to cooperate with federal law
they're saying we're not we don't
acknowledge that law is valid and that
how is that different from what George
Wallace said no it's not like that at
all this is not the first state to
become a sanctuary state or get is the
same Oregon is a sanctuary state and
organ is one of the safest states in our
Union and sanctuary states and sanctuary
cities are some of the safest places to
be in the United States it's simply not
true been studied at some length may ask
you let me ask you though California is
not one of the safest places that cities
in many cases are a mess but its economy
is in tough shape and there's more
poverty in that state and more homeless
people in that state than any other
state and California doesn't house the
67% of all the homeless in California to
have no shelter why the emphasis on
coddling people from another country
when California's own citizens and
residents are suffering in huge numbers
well these people from another country
aren't exactly hurting the system in any
single way they wouldn't be here if the
work and the jobs were not here so these
people are not hurting our system really
cuz there are a hundred and thirty-five
thousand homeless people in the state of
California overwhelming in the tour do
you have any hydrants have : have no
jobs
I have no homes okay are living outside
the overwhelming majority of them and
yet somehow there's a need for more
low-wage labor in the state why
shouldn't the state be attending to
their needs before the needs of people
who snuck in illegally
from another country whether or not
they're not coddling they're not helping
these immigrants in any way these
immigrants are here and they're giving a
driver's license they're giving them
driver's license they're paying for
schools they're paying for health care
infrastructure and you're saying
offenses yeah every illegal immigrant
working in this country is using fake
federal documents illegally that's a
felony by the way you fake doctor
they're not all paying taxes you know
that that's not true but the point is
why should the state attend to their
needs when you've got more homeless
people living in California than live in
the entire city of Dayton Ohio that's a
lot of people immigrants are paying
millions of dollars in taxes they are
helping the state and they wouldn't be
there if there wasn't work so if there's
anyone's problem are the corporations
that are hiring these immigrants what
about the colder but what about the the
Californians who were born there right
where who are naturalized Americans
reward someone else but came here
illegally right don't have work who are
again living outside why isn't their
plight priority number one why is it
that of the illegal alien why is that
persons place the sacred plight isn't
number one the undocumented persons
plight isn't number one it's simply
being a sanctuary state means that
they're not going to take the time from
these people who will call in a crime
but they're not going to tell these
people you're not wanted here you're not
not working you're not being productive
you're not helping our society they're
just saying be part of our community
calling the crimes in our community wait
hold on why aren't the governor just
sign a law designed to help the more
than a hundred thousand people living
outside in California the American
citizens living outside dying outside
why didn't he sign a law helping them
he's helping everyone by making these
people feel welcome in his state he's
helping everyone it doesn't hold on well
how does it help Americans or
Californians in this case without jobs
to welcome people to work for less than
they would make I'm undocumented
immigrants are not hurting anyone's jobs
they're not taking away anyone's jobs as
a matter of fact we need more worker
visas for these people we just don't
have a system that allows around
I'm sorry I'm really trying to I'm
trying to be patient I'm trying to track
with you logically of course how is it
that when you have a huge pool of people
who are unemployed it's helpful to those
people the American unemployed to bring
in a whole lot of other people and give
them jobs how does that help the
unemployed in America we know what's
hurting is technology and the
manufacturing jobs are gone in
technology is what's hurting workers in
America it's not the undocumented
immigrant okay so if technology is
making all the low-wage jobs going away
go away then why are we letting in
hundreds of thousands nationally
millions of people with no skills tech
skills at all
well well we had immigrations at an
all-time low so it's a mystic is no is
actually bigger in the seventies but
just interesting right now than ever
that's not true actually yes I know the
numbers but let's just in one sentence
yeah if technology is making it harder
for people who don't have advanced tech
skills right to find work right why in
the world are politicians letting in
millions of people with no tech skills
at all well because they're probably
needed they're needed there are you're
just so convenient because they're gonna
be displaced by technology well right
now they are needed these workers are
needed year-round we need visas for
these type of workers that we need to
feel comfortable in our country okay
thank you Cathy